marie good morning how are you doing
doing all right thank you for talking to
me no thank you for calling how can i
help
okay so um i'm looking for some guidance
on how to explain better to my husband
why
myself and my sister who happens to be
on
our daughter's egg donor that we feel
it's important that we share the
information about how she was conceived
with our children
we have a son that's a little bit older
and the loved ones
now before it becomes like a thing so we
can kind of control it
oh honey you can't see my face right now
but
whoa so your sister is your egg donor
she was yes does she live by you guys
uh she's about an hour away we we're
pretty close
wow okay there's a lot
and you've probably held your daughter
she's only she's gonna be three in
january so okay that's not really our
issue right now well she super is and
i'll tell you
i'll walk you through it um okay so
oh man there's a lot here
and i know it feels like there's just
one thing or two things but i promise
you there's a lot here
wowzers okay so
what was the original agreement here
and what and and i want to i want to
talk in um
i want to talk in adoption terms so was
this
a quote-unquote closed adoption did your
sister
give you an egg legally that she
terminated rights to that is completely
yours and y'all came up with some sort
of
agreement i guess um you and her and
your husband is that what happened
yes there is like legal paperwork and
everything okay
so she has terminated any and all claim
to this egg
yes and what was the agreement did you
all shake hands and say was going to
keep this quiet forever
um yeah pretty much um going into it
obviously
not knowing what was really yeah
everything's gonna explode on us yes um
okay and i know you didn't think you're
gonna get this response from me
this is a this is a messy one so
one year goes by two years go by and now
you're at three years and so then
who brings up what conversation tell me
where we're at
um okay so my sister is um
more like she's been kind of keeping her
thoughts to herself
and so we've been working through stuff
me and her and it finally this all just
kind of came out
about a year ago and then i want to know
exactly how that came out um
she finally said to me i just
feel like a donor i don't feel like you
thought about me or you think about me
or and she doesn't want like any
rights or anything like that these are
just conversations like her and i have
had but
she was feeling hurt but going into it
she did say i never want to speak about
this again
and she's five years younger than me
yeah so
so here's you have a 10 year old
biological child
you have i have a biological son and but
she doesn't have any children
okay wow okay so
oh man so here's here i'm just going to
be as honest as
as i can is that cool yeah it's probably
more than you're asking for
so the first thing that you're going to
have to put down put aside is
any sort of fantasy that this is going
to be a smooth sail for the next
rest of your life okay yeah because
here's what's going to happen
here's what's already happening is
your sister your aunt is watching a
mini-me version of herself
grow up and
slo initially it's i'm gonna do this
because it's an
awesome gift i can give to my sister
what a blessing
i don't have any kids of my own i got an
egg despair here you go i'm going to
sign all the paperwork i don't want to
talk about this again
right and then she sees somebody that
looks just like her
and then she sees somebody that responds
or curls her lip or moves her eyebrow
just like her and then suddenly
i don't want anything to do with this
but i feel like you're leaving me out
i don't want to do anything but i'm just
the donor here
and suddenly this regret this
harshness this uh and then it's well of
course we're gonna have to tell this
baby right and i know we all agreed
we y'all signed some papers of some sort
about not saying anything or jaw just
all high five each other on the way out
in the parking lot and say
no they make you legally sign papers
that's right man
and so now you've got somebody in your
house
that probably looks like your husband
and acts like you and your husband
and looks a lot like your little sister
and i'm just guessing here
and now you're recognizing
secrets destroy families so you have to
tell her
of course you have to tell her of course
right it's not
a matter of if it's when now that's dna
and
everything but you've got a husband now
who agreed to this whole thing under
another set of circumstances
however screwed up those circumstances
were
and now he feels like his world's
getting turned upside down because the
people who agree with this not like
change yes well it's not that but
he he it's not a matter of change it's a
matter of
hey i mean that doesn't like change of
plans
yeah but this is bigger than just a
change this is bigger than a change of
plans
this is a complete uprooting of
everything he thought was gonna be
happening moving forward
now i'll be the first to tell you what
he thought was gonna happen was way
wrong
but this is not just like hey i thought
we were gonna go eat at red lobster and
now we're going to burger king this is
not that
right right yes yes because here's
here if he's wise here's what he's
looking at down the road
he's looking at a series of
conversations
over the next 20 years explaining this
which isn't bad kids are resilient kids
get things
over time he'll get this or over time
your daughter will pick this stuff up
and she'll
this will be the only world she knows
right and this is great
right that's why we want to kind of make
it normal now right
but something we plan to do which we did
but
yeah of course you planned it you didn't
think it through though
because now
your husband is going to watch this
young woman grow up in your home that
looks a lot like your sister
and at the first sign of trouble
10 to 13 in that range when she knows
she's going to say something like well
you're not even my mom
and you are going to melt and
your sister my guess is will be there to
just to help out
right possibly
she's gonna have to be an ironclad woman
she's gonna have to be stronger than me
because i tell you what man if i saw
somebody
that shared my dna running around i'm
always going to have one eye looking
over there to make sure they're doing
okay
and if they fall down i'm going to be
there too it would be a very
extraordinary person who could be that
close to a situation and that
differentiated from it
right yeah
and so is your sister gonna try to
co-parent says begin to
slowly start leaning in here no
no we not like in the
relationship end of it because she feels
like
i mean she's talking to somebody about
this too but she feels like
she has the same relationship with her
that she does with
my son because she doesn't even really
technically want children
right now i know but doesn't know if she
wants them
right and so what she's getting to do is
to
presumably have the best of both worlds
right
well yeah they just send them home
that's right she got to contribute
to the making of a child you are her mom
make no mistake
right you are her mom through and
through and through
but your sister got to contribute see
what it looks like
see somebody who looks like her and grow
up and not have to deal with it
right so she's getting she's trying to
play both sides here
but i also understand man what a gift a
sister to a sister right
and i don't i don't want to think she
was an evil person at all
yeah it's a beautiful gift um
well and i think with him it's just it's
like
i don't want this to blow up and be like
it's this big secret
that she finds out later right and i
think he's more worried about like what
people his we've talked very little
about it because it blows up very
quickly
yeah um but it's like he's
he's i think he's worried that somebody
he always worries about what people
think
like they're going to be like well her
real mom
so i think it's more about like he
hasn't thought in the future part yet
but
his initial like he comes from a very
traditional family and they know very
little about our ivf
even story yeah so so like we didn't
share that because it was just easier
not to
because he would get questioned and it
was
we didn't know answers then so
yeah so worried i think about what
people are going to think
he's drowning in secrets right now
yeah i mean it was a it was i mean our
closest family like i have
all my cousins and aunts and uncles are
all right here in our same town
so like it's gonna be there's only
probably a handful of people that
actually do know
yeah so be really graceful with him
okay this is a big deal and
if he doesn't have the tools he clearly
doesn't and this isn't a knock on him
this is just a
like i i don't know how to lay tile in a
kitchen
he does not have the tools to walk
through his relationship challenges
to walk through his heartbreak over
fertility stuff he doesn't have any of
that those tools
and so what he's done is he's just kept
everything zipped up
and yeah he's losing like resentment
because at first we weren't going to do
ivf
then we weren't going to do we were
going to do our ui then we did ivf then
we were going to only do one round
then if it didn't work it didn't work
right and then suddenly you find
yourself
pushing it yeah you find yourself fifty
thousand dollars in the hole and what's
sixty thousand what's seventy thousand
right and now you're
right it was just that one more step i
just wanted my son to have a
sibling a person right that was my goal
and she stepped up she did
she did and i'm not here to judge that
process
right what i am here to judge is y'all
didn't think it through all the way
and you have to have a book on that
there's not there's not right
no and so when you find yourself in a
situation with two people that you love
here's what i'm worried about's
happening to you you're going to lose
your husband over this deal you're going
to lose your sister over this deal
because you're not talking with one
another you're not all in the same room
with one another
and you guys have to have hard
conversations all three of you together
and my guess is you're gonna have to
start with your husband
and you're gonna have to start with a
marriage counselor
tomorrow because i can't imagine
what he's trying to navigate in his head
with the limited tools he's got
right okay and i can't imagine
him feeling like his whole world is
unwinding and he may not know that the
right thing to do is to tell his little
girl
and he may not know that the right thing
to do is to not keep secrets from your
10 year old son
obviously tell people age-appropriate
things one of my
great friends um it's a husband and wife
team of therapists are incredible but
they said when you're having hard
conversations with kids
do building blocks of truth so the next
truth sits on top of that previous truth
so they don't have to
unlearn and relearn something new your
three-year-old
your 10 year old probably is not going
to fully understand sperm and egg
and implementation or implants they're
not going to get all that right
no um they do understand
a little baby takes apart from a boy and
apart from a girl and we had to go see a
special doctor to help out
they get that truth which he he knows
that we went to like special doctors
because he was there with me a lot but
yes that was three years ago he didn't
comprehend
that's right that's right so but your
husband may not know that truth
is the best way here and so i'm just
telling you be graceful with him
and as you all figure this out again
don't use language please don't use
language like he just doesn't like
change this is not just like change
right this is what i'm calling a
systemic overhaul
and then you're gonna have to be
graceful with your sister because she's
gonna watch a
spitting mirror image of herself walking
around
and she signed a piece of paper that she
didn't fully understand what she was
signing
agreed and you're gonna have to be extra
graceful
with your daughter when she says things
like you're not my mommy because you
know you are
right and you're gonna have to be oh
yeah extra graceful with your sister
when she says
well that kid's 50 mine and you can
gently say
she's not she's got 50 she's got 25
dna from her dad and 25
nurture and she's got 25 percent of your
her dna
and you're giving her the other 25 so
she's actually 75 yellow and 25
her you can use that kind of math right
other than 55 right
yeah but math answers never solve the
hole in her heart that she's going to
have
walking watching her little girl walk
around and so you're going to
end up with a much tighter relationship
with your sister if y'all will be honest
with one another or an absolute disaster
right which i think we're working
towards that i think we've come
it was pretty bad for a year or two and
i think we're
really coming together but i don't want
to be like me and her against him
yeah it can't be it's got to be the
you've got to start with him
yeah start with him and root yourself in
right so here's my meta secrets destroy
families you're going to have to create
a plan to systematically tell your kids
right very gently over a long period of
time
over and over and normalize it this is
their world
right and right that's what we have we
want to do normalize it
that's what you want to do now what he
wants to do
right correct and so when he feels like
he's being ganged up on
by somebody who just donated an egg
suddenly it feels like he's got two
wives
and he's got two mothers and he's got
two people co-parenting
do you see what i'm saying she doesn't
get a vote at this point she's out
right he gets a vote and so you want to
tell your kids
you want to improve your relationship
with him and quite honestly you i'm just
speaking for you here
but my guess is you love that man and
you want him to be able to finally drop
his shoulders and just be who he truly
is
and be a vulnerable guy that was a part
of a relationship that struggled with
fertility challenges
that he went to bed heartbroken and
lonely sometimes
and then he was able to have an
incredible opportunity to
um somebody reached up and donated an
egg and now he's got a beautiful
daughter that he loves
and if people are going to say what
they're going to say they're going to
say what they're going to say
right but he needs to learn the tools to
be able to put that kind of nonsense
down
but at the end of the day
wow you got to start from square one
with him and you got to be
graceful with him because you are
changing the rules y'all should have
thought this through
it's it's over you're here now and now
you've got a very messy situation moving
forward that can only be cured
only be helped with grace and over
communication
and honesty with one another moving
forward he's gonna have to get to a
place where he knows
secrets destroy families it destroys
children it destroys marriages
that's not an option but also you
ganging up on him with your sister
isn't an option either so start with him
start with yourself and we'll slowly
work and get there
your daughter's three so you got some
time on this deal
um and letting your son know whenever
y'all do sit down and start to have
these conversations
hey this we didn't have a playbook on
this one and so we're learning
and we probably made some mistakes we
probably did some things wonderful
at the end of the day we have a you have
a beautiful sister
that we love who lives in our house and
i'm the mom and he's the dad
and we're figuring out as we go and we
love both of you so so much
and start from there but
all of this starts on a a new foundation
of
i love my husband and we're in this
together we're in this together
sister will come along later but right
now we're in this together
marie let me know how those
conversations go if your husband wants
to give me a call i'd love to talk to
him too i'd love to get his perspective
on this this is such a unique case but
it's such a messy situation too
um have him give me a call otherwise
keep me updated on how things are going
and i look forward to hearing from you
soon
we'll be thinking about you but start
with him and start with a good marriage
counselor asap